For dedicated TV fans, getting attached to
your favorite characters is part of the fun
of watching — but things can get ugly when
one of them gets bumped off.
Whether they're objecting to the concept of
passing in general or to a particular brutal
and undeserved end, fans aren't shy about
letting everyone know how mad they are when
their fave kicks the bucket.
"How DARE you!"
Here's a look back at some of the character
deaths that have upset fans the most over
the years — and here's your chance to click
away if you don't want to see any spoilers.
"Stop it, stop it both of you, you're spoiling
it, you're spoiling everything!"
Lexa, The 100
This post-apocalyptic CW drama spurred outrage
when it bumped off Lexa, played by Alycia
Debnam-Carey.
Not only was Lexa a fan favorite, but her
development arc had just reached an important
milestone: she and her romantic interest Clarke,
played by Eliza Taylor, had just slept together
for the first time.
Fans were angry about the interrupted storyline,
but also incensed by the way Lexa's death
seemed to imply that the show saw its gay
characters as "disposable."
The backlash was so intense that showrunner
Jason Rothenberg ultimately apologized to
fans — but there was no undoing the source
of their heartbreak.
"Sex and death came so close together and
I'm aware of the optics of that being uncomfortable."
Wash, Firefly
Joss Whedon's series about outer-space cowboys
had legions of dedicated fans who were left
hanging when the show was cancelled after
just one season — a problem Whedon tried
to resolve with a follow-up feature film,
Serenity.
But while fans were thrilled to get some closure,
they weren't happy at all with this moment
in the movie's third act, when Wash, played
by Alan Tudyk, is killed by harpoon-wielding
Reavers.
"I'm a leaf on the wind….
Watch out..."
Despite being devastated, most Firefly fans
processed their grief and anger and eventually
found some peace.
But others couldn't let go; one man even claimed
that Wash's death defied the laws of physics,
just like Mal's beloved ship.
"Love keeps her in the air when she oughta
fall down."
Adriana, The Sopranos
In a mobster series that's filled with gruesome
murders, none was more tragic than the death
of Adriana La Cerva, played by Drea de Matteo.
Adriana is a good person who just wants to
escape into Witness Protection with her boyfriend,
Christopher — but Christopher betrays her,
which she realizes at the same time the audience
does in her heart-wrenching final scene.
It was so brutal that some fans tried to find
hope in the fact that Adriana was off-camera
when Silvio pulled the trigger.
Could it be that, like Tony Soprano, she's
not really dead?
"Don't stop!
Believin!
Hold on to that feeeeeeeeelin!"
Joyce Summers, Buffy the Vampire Slayer
After being ill for most of the fifth season,
Buffy's mother Joyce is finally starting to
get better.
But then, Buffy returns home to find her mother
motionless on the couch — dead from a sudden
brain aneurysm.
Many fans were deeply upset with showrunner
Joss Whedon for doing away with off Joyce — and
they weren't the only ones.
Even Buffy herself, Sarah Michelle Gellar,
argued against the decision.
"And I tried so hard to talk him out of it,
I was not happy about it."
Although most fans now agree that "The Body"
is one of the best episodes of the entire
series, processing Joyce's passing definitely
took some time, and a lot of tears.
Lane Pryce, Mad Men
Despite signs throughout season five of Mad
Men that Lane was struggling with some heavy
stuff, his self offing was still one of the most
upsetting moments in Sterling Cooper history.
The ad man played by Jared Harris had embezzled
$7,800 from the agency to cover a debt, a
crime that Don Draper discovers.
In despair, Lane returns to the agency, types
a resignation letter, and hangs himself.
"I think there's something terribly wrong
in Mr. Pryce's office."
The distraught reactions of Lane's coworkers
mirror those of fans, who were devastated
to see their favorite character meet such
a tragic, untimely end.
Derek Shepherd, Grey's Anatomy
The doctor known as "McDreamy" was central
to this Shonda-land drama — particularly
his rocky relationship with fellow doc Meredith
Grey.
But just when the couple looked like they'd
live happily ever after, a car accident leaves
Derek brain-dead.
Meredith has to make the difficult decision
to remove him from life support, a plot twist
that left many fans wanting to pull the plug
themselves... on their televisions.
"Are you ready?
-No.
But go ahead."
Colonel Blake, MASH
In this light-hearted comedy series, the sudden
and unexpected death of Lieutenant Colonel
Blake in the third season was unprecedented.
When actor McLeanStevenson decided to leave
the series, the show's creators wrote Blake
off with an honorable discharge — only to
cap the episode with a devastating epilogue.
"Henry Blake's plane was shot down over the
sea of Japan."
The show received over a thousand letters
from viewers who didn't appreciate this incredibly
depressing moment in a show that was supposed
to be funny.
And they weren't alone: the networks were
so upset about the scene, CBS even cut it
entirely in later airings of the episode.
Jax Teller, Sons of Anarchy
In the 2014 series finale of Sons of Anarchy,
the anti-hero played by Charlie Hunnam made
a controversial exit from the show — and
the mortal plane — by fleeing from the police...right
into the path of an oncoming eighteen-wheeler.
Jax's end didn't sit well with fans; some
thought he deserved better, and others thought
he deserved worse, but above all, everyone
thought that the computer-generated crows
in the final shot looked completely ridiculous.
Dan Conner, Roseanne
In the final season of the long-running sitcom
Roseanne, things take a turn for the weird.
The Conner family wins the Illinois Lottery,
Roseanne goes on Jerry Springer, Dan has an
affair, and —
"My writing is really what got me through
the last year after Dan died, I mean, at first
I felt so betrayed like he had left me for
another woman."
Wait, what?!
As it turns out, Dan is dead — taken by
a heart attack at Darlene's wedding — and
the crazy fantasies of season nine were just
Roseanne's way of coping with her grief.
Many fans and critics weren't too happy with
the bait-and-switch, but in this case, there's
good news: John Goodman's Dan will be back
from the dead in the Roseanne revival, which
is reportedly going to pretend that the show's
ninth season never even happened.
The Red Wedding, Game of Thrones
While HBO's fantasy series is notorious for
doing away off its characters, this multiple
passing is the one fans just can't get over.
After reconciling with the easily-offended
Lord Walder Frey, Robb Stark and his retinue
attend the marriage of Edmure Tully to Frey's
daughter, Roslin.
And everything seems to be going well!
Until suddenly, it isn't.
"Rob!"
Within just a few minutes, Game of Thrones
gets rid of off Robb Stark, his wife Talisa, his
mother Catelyn, and his direwolf Grey Wind.
Twitter exploded with angry, profanity-laced
tirades about the killings, with fans blaming
Walder Frey, Roose Bolton, and the Lannisters
— but also the showrunners, George R.R.
Martin, and any friends who had read the books
and didn't warn them ahead of time.
The moral of this story?
Take it away, Ramsay Bolton:
"If you think this has a happy ending, you
haven't been paying attention."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!